House Democrats are investigating an
accusation from a White House official
that the Trump administration overruled
dozens of security clearance denials
some of the names on that list are very
well-known chief intelligence
correspondent Catherine Herridge has
specifics tonight according to the
letter the Democratic chairman of the
House Oversight Committee is threatening
to issue subpoenas if the White House
fails to make records and witnesses
available after a whistleblower tricia
new bolt claimed the administration
overruled at least two dozen security
clearance denials congressman Cummings
also released a memo documenting the
complaints that according to the
whistleblower the individuals had a wide
range of serious disqualifying issues
from foreign influence conflicts of
interest to financial problems and even
criminal conduct the president's
son-in-law and advisor responded on the
Ingraham angle we've been very fully
vetted and you know totally vindicated
on all these things so for us it's
definitely been a complicated time and
service everyone makes all kinds of
accusations Democrats want records for
current and former administration
officials including John Bolton Michael
Flynn
Jerry Kushner Ivanka Trump John McEntee
Rob Porter among others the
whistleblower alleges the White House
stopped credit history checks and
allowed a high number of interim
clearances saying quote I would not be
doing a service to myself my country or
my children if I sat back knowing that
the issues that we have could impact
national security when the clearance
story broke last month a senior House
Democrat alleged a pattern I think it
was an abuse of power look the president
has a right to do a lot of things but he
can abuse his power in doing that but
Republicans say the Democrats played
games interviewing the witness early
Saturday morning
providing Republicans with no
opportunity to prepare the committee's
ranking Republicans said the
whistleblower had a hard time naming
names and one alleged clearance
violation included a janitor at the
government's office space and supplies
agency those aren't real investigations
those are fishing expeditions the
president has absolute authority to
grant a clearance to whom he thinks will
give him the best advice to do what's in
the best interest of the United States
during the Obama administration critics
questioned whether senior aides to
Secretary of State Clinton should have
been granted sensitive clearances in
addition the clearance
investigation backlog is a long-standing
issue of concern for both parties spread
kathan thank you that full interview
with Jared Kushner on the Ingraham angle
tonight 10:00 p.m.